[Musique]
on se retrouve sur le quartier l'école
pretty technique ou bien de s'achever
une balade de biodiversité organisée par
le paie à Paris Saint-Clair qui propose
aux habitants et aux gens aux usagers du
quartier de découvrir les espaces qui
ont été mis en place et qui peuvent
accueillir à la fois une faune
diversifiée de la flore tous ces espaces
de respiration du quartier
qui sont aménagés au nord de quartier de
l'École polytechnique
je crois qu'il y a pas mal d'intérêts
sur ces espaces on a beaucoup de retours
qui sont qui sont très positives au coup
de curiosité et c'est pour ça d'où la
demande de ce réseau de panneaux
pédagogiques qui ont été disposés là ces
derniers mois et qui permet d'expliquer
un petit peu et la philosophie de la
création de ces espaces
et puis leurs usages la façon dont ils
sont gérés etc c'est des sujets qui qui
intéressent beaucoup ces nouveaux
acteurs du des quartiers
les balades de biodiversité là c'est la
deuxième année que ça a lieu il y avait
une première visite qui a eu lieu une
année dernière où il y a 2 ans qui avait
eu qui avait eu pas mal de succès en
sortie de pandémie et là on a
l'impression qu'il y a vraiment une
appétence pour pour la découverte de ces
espaces dans le dans le quartier
peut-être plus largement là on est sur
le quartier de l'École polytechnique
mais ça aurait pu être aussi sur le
plateau dans d'autres dans d'autres
secteurs et je crois que l'idée c'est de
c'est de renouveler cette cette
proposition de découverte collective
d'années en année donc soit dans la
semaine de la biodiversité comme cette
année ou dans un cadre à dans un autre
cadre à définir
[Musique]